[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by the one and only
and gary rice aka honor in honor society
out tomorrow on paramount plus how you
doing today hi i'm great thank you how
are you
i'm doing great i'm so excited to talk
to you i absolutely love this film and
one of my favorite things about it was
the character of honor doing the fourth
wall
narration to us and it's cool that your
scene partner is us the audience so was
that challenging and did you study any
other fourth wall performances to
prepare
it was surprisingly not challenging
because the camera is always there
staring at you and then it was finally
like i get to look at it this is so
exciting like that's always what you
want to do because it's just there so it
was not hard i i loved it it was
it's harder to go back and to not look
at the camera i think
um
i definitely did
i mean i re-watched things to research
it so i love ferris bueller's day off i
rewatched that
i also love fleabag so i rewatched that
obviously don't need an excuse but
i took it um and easy a was another one
that
was kind of a little different because
she's talking to like her you know video
camera video diary but that's that was
another one that um
that was i think a good kind of fourth
wall break comparison
yeah and you make it look so easy too
and it's really a treat to see you do
that now it's always fun i think people
get to just embrace the actor actress
more too when they do it feels more
intimate which is awesome and did you
find a lot of and gary in the character
of honor or did it seem kind of foreign
oh my gosh no on a
i saw so much of myself in honor um when
i first read the script um also parts of
myself that you know i i
i didn't want to acknowledge like she's
we see
her flaws we see how ruthless she is we
see how competitive she is and um
i think that was so interesting for me
to see that reflected in a character in
a way that
i think is treated with a lot of care
you know that she's
she makes some questionable decisions
but um she has the audience with her and
you kind of you still want her to
succeed you still want her to be okay at
the end so i think
that was i i just loved
i i loved that aspect of it
yeah and you again just all this is just
so great to watch and it's exciting and
the movie has such a good flow but also
a great relationship in it with the
character played by gayton and did you
and gayten
with this great chemistry i have on
screen did you guys have to do chemistry
reads together or did you kind of start
just right from being on set
we had rehearsals together so we read
through all our scenes together and then
we just hung out a bunch so we watched
doctor who together um we
he makes like kraft mac and cheese and i
made him
cookies and i was like here's my
offering and he's like here's mine um
so that was great and we just we hung
out and um chatted about the characters
and
about life and yeah i gaiton is such a
gem i loved working with him no that's
awesome and that's great because like
great films great relationships and
that's just it's such an interesting
thing that happens with this film so i
don't spoil anything but really exciting
to see you guys together on screen now
people will see that the handmaid's tale
has a huge influence and is mentioned in
this film
i know you're an avid book reader you
have a great podcast the community
library podcast everyone check that out
have you read the book and are you
caught up on the show like are you a
handmaids fan
i read the book in preparation for the
movie um
i haven't seen the show
the book
i loved the book um
it's it's very intense to read i think
it's fantastic i think
many people should read it if they want
to
um
but uh yes i loved the book there were
so many quotes that i picked out that i
thought
were important to me as a person and in
the world but also were so important to
the character there are lots of
parallels there
yeah definitely and people see with the
outfits too i just love that it was
probably my favorite thing about the
film and i think the question everyone's
gonna be on everyone's mind is did you
learn karate for this or did you even
know karate maybe before this i did i
didn't i didn't know karate um it was
the it was the tiniest little little
scene we had an instructor there
everyone else there everyone you see in
the shot is like they actually do karate
um and it was at the it was at the very
end of the day and i came in and they
taught me this one thing and i was like
great let's do it um
and i had a i had a really great time i
was very nervous about it though and i
was extremely nervous i was more nervous
for volleyball which i did
try and play in high school but i was so
bad at it
so i think i was much more nervous for
that because i'd done it before and i
knew i was terrible
yeah no well look like all these things
with you it comes it looks so easy you
make it look easy you do a great job
everybody watch and gary in honor
society tomorrow
on paramount plus thank you so much for
joining me today hope to talk to you in
the future thank you so much thanks